while we're going through this rough
time together I thought I'd give you
some tips on how to help your community
and now it's time for Conan's good
neighbor tips
today's tip donate items you're not
using to neighbors in need I'm gonna
give away some great stuff to my
neighbors right now / zoom hey neighbors
I just went through the house and
Funston really nice things I'm not using
I thought I'd give them away to you is
that some good yes
first off Kathi I had this box have
never used VHS tapes yeah they're
fantastic I'm sending them your way Wow
no thank you Chris I have two packs of
these peeps they're almost within the
expiration date I'll deliver them to you
please don't hey Ronnie this made me
think of you it's a Freddy Krueger dog I
remember you said you saw that movie I
also made Conan Conan did you just do a
bunch of spring cleaning and now you're
trying to pawn your junk off on us no
Diane and that's insulting now do you
want this old toilet seat or not Conan
this was a nice time maybe you should
donate stuff people actually want anyway
State Farm wants to thank you and all
those good neighbors across the country
helping each other thanks Jake
hey I forgot to have something for you
to get your branded messaging out of my
sketch this has been Conan's good
neighbor tix